okay so today we're going to talk about
causes EB in the context of ng framework
but also in general all right my name is
Jack Russells I'm a solution architect
working in Brisbane Australia but I'm
Brazilian I've been working with
development for over 15 years now mainly
dotnet Asia in front-end development
both angular and view lately I keep this
this blog where I post quite frequently
all the stuff that I've been doing
lately and also if I have any code to
share I put on github you can find me on
Twitter if you want you keep in touch or
if you want to follow I know this stuff
that I've been doing lately so just a
show of hands here who has done any
cosmos DB before Wow it's like a third
of the room ante framework oh it's a big
number
probably 9900 the room alright so let's
let's see about the agenda so we're
gonna talk about Woody's cousin TV we
gonna check about the course because
apparently a lot of people have been
burned with cost when it comes to cosmos
I'm gonna show you how to get started
I'm gonna share some tooling and then
I'm gonna bring the F core to the mix
and show you how what you get started
with that but first let's start with
what is causal DB so I brought this
sentence from the documentation so
cosmos DB is a multi-modal
database service for managing data at a
planet scale generally classified as no
sequel okay from this sentence no
sequence quite easy scaling is quite
easy but what's the move tomorrow
because when it comes to database
multi-modal Tizen doesn't quite fit
right but the move tomorrow own causes B
means that you can have multiple api's
to talk to cousins DB and that's one
creation time when ukrainian instance
you can choose between these api's and
between these api's you have document
database graph database key value pair
database and so on so you can pick one
of those if you're familiar with one of
these api's that's really really easy to
get started
but think about costing CBS a big
umbrella so you've got these database
types where each of the API will fit
into one of them but all of them will
have these amazing features such as
global distribution the elastics the way
that scales out the consistency levels
in and all the the service level
agreement with Microsoft so when it
comes to a global solution back in the
day with sequel it would be pretty hard
to to keep two databases in two sides of
the planet to get into sync right so
imagine you had a system in Australia
with sequel a sequel database and you
you wanted to launch a new product in
the US so generally you would have two
instances of the database into side of
the planner and then you would have like
a nighttime job to sync the database
right of course that the changed now and
it's way easier but still you need a DBA
to set everything up for you if you want
to use sequel which calls will be it's
super simple so so let's see how I so
god I've got here right region in
Australia and now I want you add some
read regions across the globe so I'm
gonna add you to Asia UK US and Brazil
that's how simple is and then you save
and off you go
the data is now as close to your
customer as you can be so what's the
consistency levels what's what's all
that about
so the consistency levels is the way
that you're gonna get your data across
the regions and how fast you can get
your data and we have five consistencies
levels from the weakest to the strongest
you're gonna pay more obviously but
let's see how they they look like I'm
gonna show you in a very visual way so
it's it's pretty simple to understand so
the strong is the obviously the most
expensive one and in the top line there
in the top music wine you have the right
region and as you write all the other
regions
who
have the data at the same time all right
no delay no nothing you get at the same
time no matter where you are then you
have the bounded sailors where you have
the right region and the rich region in
a strong consistent level and the other
regions will have a slight delay which
is a hundred versions of five seconds
whichever is smaller which is good
enough for most of the applications
right then we have the session which is
the default consistence level where you
have multiple regions bounded to a
session and then in within this session
you have a strong consistency but all
there are the regions you're gonna have
a slight lay which is a bit a bit bigger
than the boundless Taylors but it's
still manageable still right then you
have the consistent prefix which start
getting all over the place so you can
see that you have delays all over but
the key point here is when you write the
data you get the data in the same order
so if you do need that data to come in
the same order and you don't want to pay
top price that's probably the one you
would you would go for in the last one
and the cheapest one is the eventual
consistency which for me when I looked
at the first time I thought why the heck
would I use that because the data is all
over the place it comes in a different
order would how would I use that but
eventual consistency has its place who
has used adventure consistency before
nor with causes to be but with anything
else no all right a couple it's actually
a pretty good idea in a lot of cases so
Amazon they store they they had they do
using the eventual CCC four for sales
right so instead of checking they stock
all the time they would just sell
without checking and then and then
eventually at the end of the day they
would consolidate that data and if at
the end of the day they didn't have this
stock just sell the data they would come
back to the customer and say hey we
don't have the product do you want to
get your money back or you want you
get something else and they found that
to be way more profitable then then
checking this talk all the time and then
if you had millions of users try and
just to buy something you would slow
down the system and people would stop
buying alright but that also applies to
anything that you want the data to come
in northern necessarily ordinary way so
you know in order for example Twitter
likes or Instagram likes or followers it
doesn't matter if you come true to Oslo
and you have one more follower than you
had in Australia but eventually that all
the data is gonna come into sync so you
have some delay but eventually and when
you stop writing you're gonna get you're
gonna get the data
I mean sync as well alright so the
comprehensive SLA is that I want to talk
about here is the agreement that
Microsoft has with their customers I'm
not from Microsoft so I'm not gonna try
to sell that but it's pretty good they
have that right so they have these
agreements regarding availability
throughput consistency in latency where
if they don't deliver what they promise
they're gonna give you the money back so
it's it's out there in the documentation
you can check if they don't believe
99.99 percent of all of those they're
gonna give you ten percent back and if
they don't deliver 99 percent they're
gonna give you 25 percent back which is
just pretty good right
so why again would use custom City Beach
start with first thing they got the
award the technical technology of the
Year award last year so it's it's
growing in popularity to start with it's
not all about popularity right when it
comes to using Casa to be its high
performances is really really good
right so it's one thing that you should
consider then availablee where you're
not gonna you're gonna go down probably
by one point zero point zero point one
percent
and it's fully managed so you don't need
a DBA to to look after the database for
you it's almost unlimited scaling so if
you need something that's gonna scale to
the roof and you don't need to be
concerned about that above from cost its
it's the one to go and for me as a
developer the multiple API is a key
because when I want to go to a new
product or new database I don't want to
learn everything from scratch so I'm
I've got a pretty strong sequel
background but if I want you go to
causes to be and I need to use for
example my learning curve would be
pretty steep because I don't have any
background on MongoDB so for me it would
be hard so for you guys who some of you
might might be comfortable with MongoDB
you can just use the API the moment they
be API in it's going to be fine all
right all right so you saw all these
amazing features they did it's pretty
nice the way that scales and all that
but what about cost cost every time I
talk to someone about causes B that cost
is something that comes up right
I saw a talk a couple of weeks ago from
this guy William Lindenberg so he put a
talk on spend ops the freaking which is
a pretty cool concept where he tracks
the usage or of each of his commands and
queries and then if someone commits a
code that's gonna start charging more he
stops the the committed to go through
which is pretty cool and to do that it
leverages the the whole cosmos db-api
because for every single request you can
check how much that cost which is pretty
awesome if you know more
this is his blog post his blog and he's
got the the video there just to show you
how it how it's done
before a lot of people cousins DB might
be expensive when they they were burned
out in the past and some people might
even start calling instead of courses DB
they start
in cosmos to be because it might be
pretty expensive
well that that can happen
that can happen if you provision the
database in a wrong way that that
definitely can happen for example let's
go now to the capacity calculator
something provided by by Asha and I'm
gonna calculate here a provision that I
usually it's usually the one that I use
right so if God 10 gigabyte of data
which is she's alright then I have for
the item size for the document size it's
like a 10 KB which looks like it's
prison or but for a record that's more
than enough right and then you have 40
right 40 reads per second and 30 writes
per second which is quite a lot for a
lot of systems so with that only pay $25
a month which is all right so it's not
expensive at all but let's say that you
move that that scale and now your item
size is almost a Meg I was supposed to
put a mag here but I didn't want to say
omegas people would go would call out
that saying that I'm a would be 1024 kb
right and then I have 20 sorry a
thousand reads per second and a thousand
writes per second this provision is
quite ridiculous but when you get to pay
that it's like 40 45 thousand US dollars
oh yeah US dollars it's quite a lot you
don't need that like it's something that
you're not gonna need ever this kind of
stuff unless you're building a system
that I don't you're gonna have
multi-million lot of uses for the system
and then it just flies to pay that the
top dollar for this kind of stuff but
I've got some stories about how I
started saving costs by moving to
Coulson DB but not only cost but the
performance as well so I've got a I had
a system that I was using sequel and I
was gathering data from multiple data
providers
and as I increase the number of
providers in them out of Donna was
ingesting Seagal sequels just not good
enough
it wasn't handling that well enough so I
had to bump up several times I had to
scale up the instance several times and
I started paying a lot of money for
sequel right so the client wasn't happy
and I I thought all right so it's time
for us to find a better solution so I
thought let's go to causes DB and see
how how that plays out and just by
moving to causes EB I was able to ingest
ten times the amount of data
I was ingesting and I started paying
half of what I was paying for sequel
just by moving that's a that's a good
thing isn't there except what I have who
here has used Radice before okay I fell
off the room so Redis just works right
it's good you create an instance and it
just works
the thing is in Asia the experience I
had with radius is the smallest instance
is more than I need and it was quite
expensive so I actually recreated a blog
post just to describe how I move to
cousins DB for the cash
so by moving to call this DB I was able
to save a hundred twenty dollars because
I was paying $150 on reddit's for the
cash
in fact that that's probably like seven
hundred crowns or something so that's
pretty good for a month right and the
performance was great so I didn't have
any issues with the performance
whatsoever all right so let's see how we
can get started with causes B so to get
started is super super simple you can go
to the portal you can click on that plus
button you can look for Kosmos DB and
then you can go ahead and at this point
in time is where you're gonna choose
your API again the API you choose in the
creation of the instance it's not
something that
all right so today I'm gonna use sequel
she talked to my database and tomorrow
I'm gonna use MongoDB as the API Doc's
use my database it doesn't work this way
you're gonna choose the API when you
create the instance okay if you need to
change in the future the recommendation
is you create another instance you
change the API and then you move the
data across alright so once you have the
instance credit they've got this really
really nice Quick Start Guide which for
me it was the best one so far that I've
seen in a in several years so you get
you go to that QuickStart and you choose
your platform I've been using done and
go for a while so I'm gonna choose
dotnet core and then you create your
items collection which is like a table a
collection is like a table in when you
compact your sequel and once that's
created you can download your sample app
which is a simple and easy application
but the thing with that is the
application that you download is linked
to your instance of the database it's
pretty cool it's just a lot of
downloading the app
f5 and then it's running you start
putting data and it goes to your
instance pretty nice so you don't need
to hack around and see where the the
connection string is and discount stuff
it's so there and then you check the
data in the data Explorer which is
pretty much like a sequel management
studio sort of thing so let's go ahead
and let's try it out so I'm gonna run a
demo here so I'm gonna go to the portal
now and I'm going to create that items
collection
so that's created I'm gonna download
hopefully not gonna take too long all
right can I extract that
and I'm gonna open the solution who here
uses writer from JetBrains know many
people people Wow
right is pretty awesome a museum writer
for the you know I was I used to use
Rishabha from read from JetBrains
for video and I loved it and and then I
decided to use writer because it's
cross-platform so I can use on on Mac as
well and pretty much the same version so
it's pretty good the only the only
problem we have brighter when you open
up the first time is that the solution
Explorer is on the wrong side of the
screen she don't like it get a fix that
all right so let's load all the package
here all right before I even show any
code as soon as it's finished restoring
I'm just gonna press the five and see
how the application looks like
all right so that should open the
browser with the application running and
we can see that happening okay there we
go
all right so that's application but
before before I create anything I'm just
gonna go to the portal okay and I'm
going to go to the data Explorer right
side is like the sequel management
studio sort of thing I'm gonna open that
in full screen so we can have in a
different tab okay so in the left hand
side here I've got the database and the
collections I've got the items
collection where right now I don't have
any document okay so what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna go back to my sample app here
and I'm gonna add some some data so I'm
gonna buy milk on my way home I'm gonna
create that I'm gonna create a couple
more so have breakfast with my mate
Jason just show more so we can have
enough that what you play with I'm going
to bring juice
for Brandon to drink alright so one last
one and I'm gonna drink more water in
the morning I'm just gonna update that I
have breakfast with my BAE Jason because
I already had breakfast with him so I'm
gonna just complete that and I'm gonna
go back to that data explorer so I can
see that data coming so if i refresh
here now you see that I have all the
data coming and that's in my instance in
in Asia right so that's how simple it is
and this one
the flag is true it is completely true
all right so let's have a look on on how
the sequel syntax is here so it's God
you can see here it's select star from
sea and the sea is is like an alias for
the collection because your your query
is context to the collection not the
whole database alright so I'm just gonna
run that to see if that works
and I've got the four records coming up
that's good alright so let's see what
else we can do so everyone will see
cohere all right Fabian cool all right
so I'm gonna check where C is complete
complete equals true alright so that
should bring only one record which date
okay but also I can remove this that is
equals true or together because that's a
boolean and that's that's gonna be true
T okay I can also put a negative in the
front and get all they're not complete
ones it's pretty much a sequel so that
that's right so let's see another
example here so we can check C name like
beer alright that's that that's a valid
sequel statement little alright so let's
run that
okay so that didn't work because these
syntax is a bit different so we need to
use contains and then yeah it's more
like JavaScript ish sort of syntax and
then that doesn't work
all right so we don't have any being
they should probably fix that you know
all right so I'm gonna remove didn't
have be either Oh God all right so I'm
gonna remove um I'm gonna check how sure
we had be there my milk breakfast oh god
geez yeah we don't read I have yes let's
let's search for water hmm where
contains C named water or sure what
that's good so what we can do as well
instead of bringing the whole document
because sometimes the document might be
pretty big you can actually get the
fields you want back instead of the
whole document right so you can specify
which fields you want okay and what we
can do also in cousin CP you have the
concept as well as store procedures
triggers and user-defined functions okay
so if we go ahead you can see that at
the top and we click on new store
procedure you can see that it's a
JavaScript function right where in C
code that will be pre painful to ride in
JavaScript that will be pretty simple
but right now I'm going to create a new
user defined function to fix that BA
issue I'm gonna create a function called
BFI and I'm gonna I expect a value out
of that and I'm going to return value
replace yeah I'm gonna use regular
expression to replace by beer so who
here likes regular expression nobody our
traffic up of
that's good cause regular expression all
right so I'm gonna replace that globally
with no keys since DV and I'm going to
replace Jews I'm gonna replace Mora I'm
gonna replace breakfast and go all right
I'm gonna I'm gonna fix that issue all
right so I'm going to save that you just
close these up and I'm going to call the
user-defined function here purify and
I'm gonna put in an alias for for the
name should be named again all right and
when I when I execute that you can see
that now that I can know by beer on my
way back home have beer with my mate
Jason oh sorry
[Music]
bring beer for Brandon to drink and
drink more beer in the morning I don't
know if my leave is gonna survive with
that but it's fine
all right so the next thing I want to
show you is this solution itself and how
that that solution that simple solution
is gonna work okay so let me open it up
for you it's a other side is a very very
simple solution it's got an item
controller
we'll screen that and the end point that
we used for this demo was the create a
sink not this one okay and it's calling
the it's bringing the item and it's
calling the repository the create a sink
from the repository and you can see on
the top of the repository we have all
the configuration that we need for my
instance of the EDUCAUSE multi-beam
right so it's it's already there for me
we're not downloaded so if I need to
change that you know the instance that's
the place where I would change right
obviously this configuration shouldn't
be here when you go to production should
be app settings or something like that
but that's that's good enough okay all
right so the next thing I wanna show you
here is in the CS brush and that's the
package that you use for that
that's a package they use the document
DB package eventually when they go to
version 3 they're gonna change that to
causal TB instead but for now that's
working right so I instantiate the
client the document client here and then
I use that to create the document all
right and that's how simple it is all
right so what about the tooling I did a
talk about a year and a half ago about
logic apps back in the day and during
the process what I did was I was
ingesting a bunch of tweets and I was
putting in Kosmos DB right and after the
talk
I had this massive amount of data and I
wanted you to go there and just to see
what I would do with this tweet just to
analyze these tweets and all but I
didn't have time I was pretty busy I've
got to read through heat so it was
pretty hard to get back to those tweets
and check it out
so I left the instance running so I was
being like a hundred bucks a month but I
was oh my god I don't have time to do
that right now so I was keep paying and
eventually I found out that was it
a tool that I wished I found out about
that before to migrate the data all
right so that's one tool that I use
quite often where I can bring the data
to causes the be or our of course on the
DB right which is pretty simple it comes
it's still from the document DB days but
it works very well so let's have a look
at the demo here so from my aja causes
to be instance what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna launch the data migration tool
here okay so I'm gonna select document
DB I'm gonna bring this connection
string from our instance that we just
created from the case and I'm going to
copy that
don't take photos of the connection
strings please all right so I'm gonna
paste that here I know that the doc the
database name is should you least and
the collection name is items all right
so I can enter the query here or select
the query from somewhere else but I'm
gonna just put select star from C and
what I can do here I can put you in all
that causes to be instance but what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna just export as a JSON
file I'm gonna put children in here I
could pretty Phi but uh won't bother
this time and I can just import alright
so it takes not even second and then
I've got the data in there and if I
check the data I've got all my data
coming from causes the B okay so if I
knew about this tool before I could just
export the whole data and I could stop
paying at that point on
the other thing that you should consider
actually the other thing that you need
to have in my opinion if you're gonna do
any cousins to be in development is they
cause with DB emulator unfortunately
that's only for Windows which for me it
was pretty downside because I also have
a Mac but what you can do is it emulates
an instance of causes it to be locally
all right so you can play with pretty
much all the features obviously it's not
going to scale or any of that thing's
not going to global distribute but you
can use all the features that you need
for your development so let's see how we
can do with the emulator so I'm just
gonna start a demo here I'm gonna kick
off the emulator
okay so when it starts you can see that
it it even looks like Asia right but
it's still running on localhost so what
I can do now I can go back to my sample
app and I can use that the local
instance instead of my Asia instance all
right so I'm gonna go here close down
I'm gonna go here to my repository and
I'm gonna paste that connection string
gonna remove that endpoint and put on
top I'm gonna clean this key here I'll
keep the database ID in the collection
the same and may not round out eat both
creates my database in my collection and
then I can start putting data in there
all right
let's create an item here you can see
that in the data Explorer we've got the
to do list in the items because it
created that automatically but I have no
records so I'm going to go to the simple
app and I create a new a new instance
here that's the local instance and I'm
going to create and cool so I'm now
using a local instance of course on CB
right there is he alright so now that I
that I have my development environment
set up I can start using EF core so I
can bring EF core to the mix and start
playing with that but before before I
get to that point I just want to tell
you a bit of a story about his this
package right when I found out that they
were gonna release a provider for Cosmo
CB for EF call I was pretty excited I
was super excited because I love cousins
we had time and I was using the F core
all the time so for me it was it was
gonna be like a happy marriage right and
then at a time I even wrote a blog post
I was super excited I wrote all the
others steps to get started and all that
and you know how H was school and I left
there for a while and then eventually I
was accepted to speaking a conference
and I was pretty excited as well and I
thought alright so wouldn't you get a
dogs gonna be easy cuz I've got a post
that that's fine I can just go there and
get the source code and create a demo
for the for the talk and then I went
through my own steps and that's why I
use a blog in the in the first place you
remember what I did in the past and when
I went through these steps the package
wasn't coming out I tried multiple in
multiple ways to add then you get
packaged but it wasn't coming up and I
thought that's going on like what am I
doing wrong like I'm doing step by step
everything
right shouldn't shouldn't break and then
eventually I got the source code they
would source code and eventually I found
a link straight to the new guide package
you got walk so thought that's good
alright so now I can breathe now so I've
gotten you get peckish that's good and
then I I took a closer look and I saw
this yellow box here and I was about to
go to a conference right the owner has a
list this package this could mean that
the package is duplicated or shouldn't
be used so was about you presented in a
big conference and I was gonna present
on something that's deprecated so that
that's my my feeling at the time I was
freaking out like how can I present or
something that's deprecated and then I
found out that yet they just renamed the
package and they just drop the dot
sequel at the end and also I was happy I
could breathing here that's good so
let's have a look let's let's have a
look at the demo and and this time what
we can do I'm gonna use a code base that
I created and previously it's a really
simple one and you can find that in my
github repository so I'm gonna copy
again that connection string and I'm
gonna use my own code base to start
playing with that and I'm gonna go
through the whole process of how I put
together you know alright I'm gonna open
with writer again
alright so the solution itself is quite
simple
and I'm gonna go to the app settings
here and I'm going to pass you to paste
or the connection strings and end point
and the db9 okay DB name is gonna be
blog all right okay so just so you can
see here as I said it's a it's a pretty
simple solution and I've got three
entities author category and post any
post I have references to author and
category simple as that okay in in the
controller what I have is a simple post
controller and I've got only two
endpoints once you get all the posts and
want to create a post
okay so if I go now to the create post
itself you can see it's it's quite
simple so I'm getting the model I'm
initiating an entity I'm binding all the
properties from the model to the entity
all right I'm creating an author and
category so nothing too fancy I'm not
looking for existing categories or
authors at this point on and then I go
and I add that post using anti framework
oh cool and save the change so that's
how you usually do anyway right so you
get an NT framework and then you use
that to interact with the database okay
so let's have a look at the DB context
itself and it looks Reva Nilla right so
it's got a cup of DB sets and that's
that's it so if god two constructors
there just to ensure that the database
is created but that's about it there is
nothing else so it's gonna work the same
way you used to work with NT framework
the only difference though is here in a
startup instead of using sequel we have
that in the add dbcontext we are using
cosmos right and that's bringing from
the connection string and also we are
adding into the framework cosmos to the
startup simple all right so let's kick
it off and see how that how that works
I'm just gonna f5 here shouldn't take
long
all right so I'm gonna kick off the
application here all right so you can
see that in the in the Explorer in that
Explorer I've got a new database called
blog and I've got this collection called
blog dbcontext so the first time I saw
that I'd I didn't quite like yeah I
didn't like the fact that the collection
itself was called after the DB context
name anyway so it shouldn't be a big
deal right so you can see that we'd have
any documents and we can create a new
post here just to try it out so getting
started with cosmos D being the catalyst
cause once the author is Jaco passes and
the content is awesome
I'm gonna add that alright so if I go to
the data Explorer again for my surprise
when i refresh that I've got three
documents alright so I was expecting
when I when I first did that I was
expecting to have a single document for
the post right but I've got three you
can see here these one is supposed you
can see the content is awesome and the
discriminator exposed around screen
reader and the title is getting started
with cousins DB but I also have
reference to author ID and category ID
and then I realize that that's actually
pretty clever because it's implementing
polymorphism out of the box without no
configuration at all okay so you have
all your data in a single collection so
you don't need to worry about sharing
that that throughput of causes to be
into multiple collections you can use a
single collection for you your whole
database but in some cases that's not
good enough you want to split that up
right but you start with what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna fix that problem where we
have the default collection as the name
of the DB context because I didn't like
that so I'm gonna override that using
the Oh more oak reading of the DB
context
and I'm gonna override here the
convention of Cosmos and I'm the default
container named is now going to be
default
all right instead of being the name of
the dbcontext I'm just going to use the
fault for now so if I run that what I
should see instead of the blog to be
contest context I should see a default
collection in all the data should be
going to this default collection instead
all right so I'm gonna refresh this page
here I'm gonna have a look at my data
Explorer and you can see now I have the
default collection if I create a new
post cause them to be cosmos Thiago and
the content is great
all right so that's graded and if we go
back shoot the data Explorer we can see
that we have the same thing all right
okay so I was a tiny happier because now
I can I can dictate what what the name
of the collection is you start with Ryan
but I in some cases you don't want all
the entries or your documents to be in
the same pile in the same collection so
I'm gonna fix that as well because I
wanted posts to be in a different
collection I don't care about the
authors in in calories I'm happy for
them to be in the default collection but
for posts I want then it should be in
its own collection right so I'm gonna
override a container named footballs and
what I should expect now is when I
create a new a new post I will have the
post document in the post collection and
everything else in the default
collection so I have no post at this
point in time but now when i go to my
data explorer I've got posts in there
with no documents okay so I'm gonna go
ahead and I'm gonna create a new post
you post Cosmos water tiago content
grade change add alright so when I go to
my data Explorer now I have a single
document in the post collection and if I
go back to my default collection queue
all the documents will create it there
once the author and one fork a category
all right so that's pretty good and
that's the way I would normally do leave
all the auxilia data in its own
collection and the data that I need the
most I would put in in a separate
collection but in some cases you might
you have one-to-one right so you might
have you might want each to be set to be
in its own collection so I create these
this
this is nip adhere which is gonna just
go through the DB sets of the DB context
and just override they contain a name
all right
that's a solution that you can take I
usually don't do that
I leave them in in a signal collection
but if you do want you to do that you
can if I finish running that and I
create a new record now refresh that you
can see that the calorie well let's wait
a second you can see that the calorie
and the author is not coming back now
because now they are pointing to a
different collection altogether only the
post is coming back but now when I come
here to the data Explorer I have two new
collections authors in calories so now I
have each to be said should be pointing
to its own collection again it's not
something that I would do in real life
but if you do want to do that you can
right so let's go and create a post to
see how that works
if I go to that Explorer now I have one
author I have one category and I have
one more post coming up cool all right
so what's next
so if you want to use the EF call
provider for cousins EB they maintain
this this task list right now it's in
version 3.0 point 0 preview something
but they have a lot of features already
in place ok so if you think that the
features they have is good enough for
you you should just start using so let's
have a quick look so that's the the
issue that I have on github and these
are the tasks that they maintaining so
they don't have a date for our team yet
but they already have a lot of features
and it's going to be good enough for a
lot of people all right so let's
summarize so what is going to be in why
simply because it's awesome but well you
should should give it a try anyway it's
amazing and it's got amazing features
and you should definitely give it a try
if you have time the getting started I
love the need f5 experience it's so
simple and for someone even starting
with development itself it's super
simple to get started the wiring happy
of wiring up of VF core for me it was a
really clever implementation so you have
polymorphism out of the box with no
configuration or when you need to be if
you needed to do that with Seco that
would be a major hassle right and I
shared also some tooling how you can do
a local development and also how you can
migrate the data across and what's next
just watch out for that task list if
that's good enough for you just give
get started thank you very much I think
we've got time for some questions if you
guys have any questions happy to answer
yep the question is if that works with
the multi partition of course on TV I'm
not using partition with with the EF
core provider yet I think they're on the
way though yeah when I want to use
partition I used the main document
db-api any more questions yep
all right so the question was how do you
structure your course needs to be either
split into multiple collection or
keeping one collection only it's a it's
a really different way of singing and
structuring your data because with
Kosmos be--that's it's a document
database right under the covers and you
shouldn't use a document database as a
relational database because it's not so
my suggestion Masha Gessen means
suggestion is keep everything that you
need for that document for that context
within that context and then that's how
I use write for example of using cousins
DB to track market data in price and
things like that and I have not only the
market details in its document but all
the positions of the market in the same
document so the document is a bit bigger
obviously but it's all it's all
condensed in one document and if you
need less details of that document again
you can just point which properties you
want and then you get less data for
example if you want to list all the
documents or list all the posts all you
need is the ID and the title or
something like that you can easily just
grab that data instead of grabbing the
whole database any more questions
yes all right so the question was sequel
and yes itself has the migration concept
how does that work with cousins do be
again cause with DB is the doctrine
database and you don't really need
migration so it's not like if the field
is not there it's gonna crash as it
would in sequel if the fields not there
it's just not gonna bring the data and
if you add that extra data it's just
gonna add later on right so it's not
like you need migrations because as you
add more fields to your document or to
your entity this is gonna start adding
to your document so it's not gonna crash
but for previous data if you do not have
that data before where we have to back
view that anymore
yep
hmm that's a great question so the
question was regarding to security how
how the security security is handled in
causes to be if you have like item level
security
so it's compliant with GDP I and all I
haven't gone through that path yet the
only security that I I've been doing is
in the database level or collection
level but if you do want to do that my
suggestion would be to go through the
API they will API would handle the
security and that's how I've been doing
instead of securing in the database
itself I secure that in the API so when
you go there you check if you do have
access to some sort of data and then you
will only bring the data that you have
access to but yeah that's a great
question yes yep
all right so the question was the
regarding the multi modal underneath is
not always document database so you can
have the keep key value pair the table
the the graph database the document
database in one or the one that I I
forgot so depending on the API that you
choose for example if you use Grambling
you're gonna use one type Cassandra I
think it's graph graph database if I'm
not mistaken and if you use MongoDB or
cause or the call which is sequel it did
you use doctrine database but the other
ones don't use the document database
they have just to see what you need does
that make sense yes so if you use the
sequel a P I under the covers it's gonna
be a document database yes yeah anything
else all right that's a wrap thank you
very much